immediate certainty does not take over
the truth for its truth is the universal
whereas certainty wants to apprehend the
this
perception on the other hand takes what
is present to it as a universal
just as universality is its principle in
general
the immediately self differentiating
moments within perception are
universal i is a universal
and the object is a universal that
principle has arisen for us and
therefore the way
we take in perception is no longer
something that just
happens to us like sense certainty on
the contrary it is logically
necessitated with the appearance of the
principle
the two moments which in their appearing
merely occur
also come into being one being
the movement of pointing out or the act
of perceiving
the other being the same movement as a
simple event or the object perceived
in essence the object is the same as the
movement
the movement is the unfolding and
differentiation of the two moments
and the object is the apprehended
togetherness of the moments
for us or in itself the universal as
principle is the essence of perception
and in contrast to this abstraction both
the moments distinguished
that which perceives and that which is
perceived are the
unessential but in fact because both are
themselves the universal or the essence
both
are essential yet since they are related
to each other as
opposites only one can be the essential
moment in the relation
and the distinction of essential and
unessential moment must be shared
between them
one of them the object defined as the
simple entity
is the essence regardless of whether it
is perceived or not
but the act of perceiving as a movement
is the unessential moment
the unstable factor which can as well be
as not be
with paragraph 111 we're entering a
brand new section of hegel's
phenomenology
we have spent quite a bit of time now
exploring the preface and the
introduction
and then we got into the first part of
consciousness and we began
naturally enough with what might appear
to be
most truthful most immediate most easy
to take for granted some sort of
foundation point upon which we could you
know begin everything else
and that was sense certainty now we're
transitioning
from sense certainty into something a
bit more complex but also something
as it turns out within the hegelian
point of view something a bit more
real something a bit closer to the way
in which we relate ourselves to to
things to our perceptions to
each other to the the world that we
share
in perception and as i put it out in the
section
just previous to this in the video for
that one
hagel is going to play off of the fact
that in german
perception this is the the
substantive for it where we're talking
about the activity var nemo
but it can also be our name and the verb
right and this nemong
or neyman
means a variety of things but they all
have to do with
taking they all have to do with with
gripping with grabbing with with holding
on to something
the var has to do with the true
or truth so in perception we are
grasping
the truth or not in other terms the
essence
of what's there in front of us we're not
yet turning it on ourselves
and becoming self-conscious that's going
to come about later on
although there is going to be plenty of
interplay here where as we're looking at
this important stage of consciousness
this gestalt
we're going to see that we are going to
pay attention to the
subject as well as the object of
perception
so as we start this he says immediate
certainty does not take over the truth
this is something that we've realized
for the truth is what the universal that
was one of the hard-won achievements of
the previous section realizing
that we're never grasping something
just as it is we're always bringing it
under
you might say the rubric or the aspect
of some sort of universal and we
explored what a universal
is hegel has a very interesting way of
describing it
in terms of being a negation of all of
its moments and yet it's identical with
its moments
there's there's a lot more to it that
could be said there but we've already
explored that
so he says certainty wants to apprehend
the this the truth is universal
certainty wants to apprehend this how do
we bring those two together
how do we bring together the particular
what appears to be immediate
and the mediation that's going on within
the universal so he says
perception on the other hand takes what
is present to it
as a universal perception is working in
a different way
so with perception we have a subject who
is doing the perceiving we have this act
of perception as we'll see in a moment
and what is being perceived is being
perceived as a
universal piece of chalk right i don't
just
i can have sense certainty of this as
being white
and you know certain hardness and
certain sound to it we could do all this
whole
exercise and all these qualities but
when i'm perceiving it i'm perceiving it
as
piece of chalk you're perceiving it in a
somewhat different way than i am but
you're perceiving it as
piece of chalk as well you don't know
that this is actually chalk
do you i do because i'm holding it in my
hands
this could in fact be a pencil eraser
that i put liquid paper on to make it
look white and i just wanted to fool
you that's also something that's going
to come up in this discussion as well
with perception we also become
interested in the possibility of
deception as well but that's going to
come in later paragraphs
let's go back to this so we have the
object being grasped as the universal
so he says just as university
universality is its principle in general
the immediately self-differentiating
moments within perception are universal
okay so that what does all that verbiage
mean
that means that when we're looking at
something like this we can say a piece
of chalk
we could also say pieces of chalk right
and these are moments within the
universal piece of chalk
or white cylindrical thing
or something to write on the blackboard
with or
things in dr sadler's hands it doesn't
necessarily matter
what universal we're talking about
we can bring a unity to disparate things
by by putting them all under one
universal
so he says that principle has arisen for
us
and therefore the way we take in
perception is no longer something that
just
happens to us like sense certainty now
this is an important point it's really
easy to pass
over this as you're reading through this
because you're tempted to like get to
the end of the paragraph
figure out what he's saying but this is
one that's
very important to linger over for just a
moment
what is hegel actually getting at in
saying this
the principle has arisen for us what is
a principle a principle is something
that
is universal principle is something
that the greeks called an archaic
something that's a beginning something
that determines other things
that provides us with a conception that
we can then
apply in other cases so he says it
therefore the way we take in perception
is no longer something that just
happens to us like sense certainty
what's going on here
is something that has more logical
determinateness something that we can
say has its own internal necessity
it's not purely contingent like i happen
to be walking around and taking in this
and taking in that
there's something much more important
something much more intelligible
going on so what is that he says with
the emergence of the principle the two
moments
we're talking about the object the
universal is one of these moments
and the perceiving eye as another moment
two moments uh which in their appearing
merely occur
also come into being that is they attain
a kind of status a kind of reality that
they didn't have
or at least wasn't apparent in them
before
so he says one being the movement of
pointing out or the act of perceiving
the other being the same movement as a
simple event
or the object perceived so what we have
here
from the perceiving eye the perceiving
eye
is what it is it has its being through a
kind of agency
it is a perceiver insofar as it is doing
perception right and the object of the
universal doesn't just sit there like a
lump unless it happens to be a lump of
course
it is an event it involves a kind of
movement that is involved in being
perceived
this is not something purely static that
is just being approached by the active
subject
there's an interplay between the two of
them so it says
in essence the object is the same as the
movement the movement is the unfolding
and differentiation
of the two moments what are the two
moments
this universal here this universal there
now as he goes on we're going to be
posed with a really interesting question
where's the essence where is
the you might say the real show
what we're really after here what's most
essential in this process
and hegel is going to pose to us a
couple different possibilities
maybe neither one of these is really
essential
maybe they're both essential maybe
just one of them is but in that case
which one is it
so let's look at each of these in turn
he says
for us or in itself the universalist
principle is the essence of perception
and in contrast to this abstraction both
the moments distinguished that which
perceives
and that's what which is perceived are
the unessential
so that's a little strange isn't it
let's go back over that one more time
what he's saying is yes there's a
universal here and there's a universal
here
and both of them are universals which
means
they have something in common so neither
one of them
effectively captures what's really going
on there
at first we'd be tempted to say well we
have like a
surplus of universals we got one over
here we got one over here this is an
essence that's an essence
but what's going on here is
we're losing our hold on what is what he
has being
there's something more there's something
surplus here so this is the the process
of
negation that's going on he says the
universalist principle is the essence of
perception in contrast to this
both the moments are the unessential but
in fact because both
are themselves the universal or the
essence both are essential so what is it
how do we resolve this
we have a and not a at the same time
which is it going to be so he says since
they are related to each other as
opposites we have to make a choice only
one of them
can be the essential element now when we
were looking at
sense certainty and we had to deal with
this sort of thing where is the real
essence we generally put it on the side
of the object right
that which is imposing itself upon our
consciousness that that's what
consciousness is taking in
instead over here we're going to say
with perception at least at the very
beginning of it
that the perceiving i is what is most
universal the perceiver not the
perceived the perceived ver
is doing the same sort of perceiving no
matter what
content we're dealing with over here so
that's a very promising beginning point
isn't it
he says one of them the object must be
defined as simple entity
simple being something that is
is the essence regardless of whether
it's perceived or not but the act of
perceiving as a movement
then becomes the unessential moment so
we have another dynamic
shift here and we're going to lose our
grasp
on what is really essential and we're
going to waver back and forth and back
and forth throughout the rest of this
section so we had universal taking it
away
we go here and now we come back over
here once again
he says the act of perceiving is the
unessential moment the unstable factor
which can as well
be and not be so let's think about
what's going on here
over here we have being in itself it
is whether there's a perceiver to
perceive it or not
or at least we think so at this point
over here
we have the perceiver there's no
perception if there isn't a perceiver to
do the action of perceiving
and yet it's contingent whether there's
going to be a perceiver
that's what we're what we're going to
begin with that's our starting point for
this section
this object must now be defined more
precisely and the definition must be
developed briefly from the result that
has been reached
the more detailed development does not
belong here
since the principle of the object the
universal is in its simplicity a
mediated
universal the object must express this
its nature
in its own self this it does by showing
itself to be the thing with
many properties the wealth of sense
knowledge belongs to perception
not to immediate certainty for which it
was only the source of instances
for only perception contains negation
that is difference or manifoldness
within its own essence
paragraph 112 is very short and there's
not a lot going on there but what is
going on
is something that we do want to talk a
little bit about because it's going to
show us where we're going in just a few
more paragraphs
so he begins by talking about the object
and he's reminding us once again that
the object has been revealed as the
universal
right and he says we're going to define
it more precisely and the definition
must be developed briefly from the
result that has been
reached so we're summing things up at
this point trying to get our head around
where we've been so far so he said the
principle of the object the universal is
in its simplicity
a mediated universal that means that the
self of the
object is going to have to contain that
immediacy
and by this point in in the study
whenever you see the term media c
you should be thinking aha we're moving
ahead with something
things are not going to be in a couple
paragraphs what they are right now
but you should also be thinking a couple
other terms like you should be thinking
negation
you should be thinking how things are
connected with each other here
hegel is going to figure it in terms of
difference and
multiplicity or as the translation here
has manifoldness
money faulty kite you know it can be be
translated as either way multiplicity or
manifold-ness
and we're going to move from the object
to the thing
um i suppose it's good to know that
he's talking about the ding you know
that that has certain resonances because
kant had said well we can never really
get to the thing in itself
and hegel is going to you know go beyond
that uh this has all sorts of other
connotations
that hegel doesn't himself uh
necessarily intend but later people are
gonna pick up on and run with you know
the meaning of the thing
but you know so if we just stick with
thing that's fine the english
you know cognitiveness and what's really
important
here is that we're looking at the object
as the thing with many
qualities or many properties eigenshaft
he's going to do a play on words with
the eigen dealing with that in a little
bit
and when we talk about something having
properties
again think about this piece of chalk
what properties does it have it has
hardness
right it has a certain durability
it has a certain taste i'm not going to
taste it right now because i know what
chalk tastes like
it's white it's uh chalky you know if we
want to be circular about it
and it fits in my hand in a certain way
it's very dry it's actually drier than
most dry things because it makes my
hands dry as well
those are properties those are the ways
in which we know the thing
and in a certain sense these properties
are themselves universals but they're
being perceived they're being grasped
through
sense knowledge that's what the richness
of sense knowledge provides us with when
we look at a thing
we see its properties we take those
properties in
it's not for nothing that the ancients
often thought of us sort of
taking in in some sort of uh you know
metaphorical way
the thing itself into ourselves and
grasping
its properties within our soul or our
mind
now hegel is going to stress he's just
mentioning it here but it's going to
play a very important role
that these properties are marked by
difference and multiplicity
among themselves and we'll just leave
off with that because we're going to see
how this plays out
but the key thing here is that
perception
or knowledge through the senses is
taking place by moving to look at the
thing
which has many properties
the this is therefore established as
not this or as something superseded and
hence not as
nothing but as a determinant nothing
than nothing of a
content that is of the this
consequently the sense element is still
present but not in the way it was
supposed to be in the position of
immediate certainty
not as the singular item that is meant
but as a universal or as that which will
be defined as
a property supersession exhibits
its true two-fold meaning which we have
seen in the negative
it is at once a negating and a
preserving
are nothing as the nothing of this
preserves its immediacy
and is itself sensuous but it is a
universal immediacy
being however is a universal and virtue
of its having mediation
or the negative within it when it
expresses this in its immediacy it is a
differentiated
determinate property as a result
many such properties are established
simultaneously one being the negative of
another since they are expressed in the
simplicity of the universal
these determinacies which are properties
strictly speaking
only through the addition of a further
determination
are related only to themselves
they are indifferent to one another each
is on its own and free from the others
but the simple self-identical
universality is itself in turn distinct
and free from these determinate
properties it has
it is pure relating of self to self or
the medium
in which all these determinancies are
and in which as a simple
unity they therefore interpenetrate
but without coming into contact with one
another
for it is precisely through
participating in this universality
that they exist indifferently on their
own account
this abstract universal medium which can
be called simply
thing hood or pure essence is nothing
else
than what here and now have proved
themselves to be
that is a simple togetherness of a
plurality
but the many are in their
determinateness simple universals
themselves
this salt is a simple here and at the
same time
manifold it is white and also tart
also cubicle in shape of a specific
gravity and so forth
all these many properties are in a
simple
single simple here in which therefore
they interpenetrate
none has a different here from the
others but each is
everywhere in the same here in which the
others are
and at the same time without being
separated by different here's they do
not affect each other
in this inter penetration the whiteness
does not affect the cubicle shape
and neither affects the tart taste on
the contrary since each is itself a
simple relating
of self to self it leaves the others
alone and is connected with them
only by the indifferent also this also
is thus the pure universal itself or the
medium the thing hood which holds them
together
in this way
there's a lot going on in paragraph 113
and you might see it as something almost
like a labyrinth
that you need an ariadne's thread to
make your way through
but what we're going to see is that a
lot of what he's talking about here
turns out to be fairly straightforward
so long as we just take it one step at a
time so let's let's do that
let's look at what he's talking about
first the the book
that we're using the translation uses a
super session as au fable
in in the german we've seen that out of
hebong is
or out of haben in the verbal
cognitive of the term is used to
describe this process
of negating but also preserving
at the same time that he he's talking
about in this section
and it's when dialectical progress takes
place that there's some sort of outflow
not necessarily from one entire stage of
consciousness to another
but also it describes the process of
movement
within the stage of consciousness as it
develops
so he begins by talking about this kind
of general schema
we begin with this and we
negate it so we get a not this and then
the question is
is that not this a nothing or
is it something else is it a not nothing
it's not a pure nothing instead it's a
determinant
nothing and that determinant nothing
refers back to this because it's a
nothingness
of this that was there in the this the
whole time
just sort of waiting to be brought to
light waiting to be made determinate
now what why is he talking about that at
this point why
is he just you know jumping into all
this metaphysical stuff well because it
has something to do with
with our perception so we began with
the sense element as he calls it and we
began with it in certainty we treated it
as of this
i'm there what's present impinges itself
upon my consciousness i take it in
and as it turned out it's not quite so
simple as that
we found that ultimately the truth of
sense certainty
lay in the universal that the singular
which was being meant which was being
intended
whenever we said the word this turned
out to be
in certain respects unreal unsayable in
language
and because language and thought are
connected together in a certain way even
unthinkable and the universal became
where the the weight the gravity
moved to and now we're seeing that we're
moving
uh to further understand this to make it
more concrete
we're understanding in terms of the
property
the universal immediacy as hegel is
going to call it so let's
let's actually look at that little
characterization that he has he says
um are nothing as the nothing of the
this that this
that was over here preserves its
immediacy and is itself
sensuous so when we're perceiving
something
when we're engaging in perception of a
property
it's not that we're no longer using our
senses
it's not a purely intellectual activity
we are still using our senses
but we perceive the property in the
thing i perceive the whiteness
in the chalk now you might say oh wait a
second
hegel dr sandler all you're really
seeing are light waves coming from that
and in a certain sense that's what
modern science teaches us
but if you actually want to do a
phenomenological analysis of what
consciousness is like our consciousness
reaches out into the world of things
and it it perceives the properties
there's something
more than just light waves
going on there is an active uh role that
we're playing in constituting that as
the phenomenologist would say
so it's it's universal because it's
grasping the universal
but it's grasping it in immediacy or in
sensibility
now hegel is not going to stay there for
very long
anytime you see the word immediacy
figure that
we're not done yet right so he goes on
and he says that
when we look at a property more closely
what do we find out
its immediacy is a differentiated
determinate property
what does that mean well
here's where we need to do a little bit
of erasing just to get us ready
when you differentiate what's going on
if i'm going to differentiate say
white chalk from blackboard
we have two things don't we or i say i'm
a human being
this is just a tool for my use
or i'm a human being and you're another
human being we're differentiating
we're splitting things into a
multiplicity
and when we do that in terms of
properties matter of fact
let me get rid of even this because
we're not going to need that right now
we have a differentiated determinate
property of some sort now what it means
for that to be differentiated
is it has to be differentiated against
another
property or
multiple properties
we can differentiate in multiple ways we
can say the chalk is white it is also
not black it is also not
red it is dry it is not wet we're
differentiating that way
right we're also making it more
determinate that way
but we can also differentiate within the
perception of the piece of chalk we can
say
it is white and it also is hard
and it also is cylindrical and it also
is
pointed and it also you see how we're
doing that there
we're describing a thing in terms of its
properties
so he goes on and he says as a result
many such properties are established
simultaneously
it doesn't matter which one we
originally begin with the chalk could be
white
it could be hard it could be you know
tasting
funny it could be dry it doesn't matter
which one we actually start with because
all the properties are there
simultaneously that is within the same
experience within the same time
he goes on and he says one of them
is the negative of another since they're
expressed in the simplicity of the
universal
these determinacies which are properties
strictly speaking only through the
addition of a further
determination are related only to
themselves
they are indifferent to each other
now you know we could put more
properties on the board i'm going to
keep it simple just keep it at three
right
so they're originally indifferent to
each other the white doesn't care
that the the white is there in something
that's also hard
the heart doesn't care as far as being
hard about the whiteness that's there
they don't they don't care about each
other so so far as they care we're
doing a little anthropomorphizing here
so he says
these determinacies are indifferent to
one another each is on its own and free
from the others
so we have you know we're going to use
the chalk here we have say
whiteness whiteness is what it is
it's here we sense it but it's just by
itself
hardness
um dryness
you don't actually need to know anything
about whiteness in order to understand
what dryness is or at least to perceive
it
through your senses right
now things get more interesting when we
say well yeah but
don't we have a piece of chalk here well
yes we do
so we need to go on he says the simple
self-identical universality is it is
itself in turn distinct and free from
these determinate properties he has
it's a pure relating of self to self
or the
medium in which
all these properties are
and in which is a simple unity they
therefore interpenetrate they are
able to be there with each other they
are able to interconnect
they are able to be part of one
experience but without coming into
contact with one another for it is
precisely through participating
in this that they exist indifferently on
their own account
so what is this medium what is holding
everything together
what is providing them the locus in
which this can take place
that's a trick question that's going to
lead us in a couple different directions
what's the first one that we would think
of it says this abstract universal
medium
which can be called simply thing hood
or pure essence
is nothing else than what here and now
have proved themselves to be a simple
togetherness
of a plurality we have a plurality a
multiplicity
and we have something here that's you
know a universal it's bringing them all
together
within some determinate thing in this
case
the thing hood happens to be a piece of
chalk in another case it could be a cup
of coffee in another case
it could be this blue uh glasses cleaner
fabric right we can pick anything that
we want
and we can talk about this in general
ways because
we're not just thinking about you know
this property and that property and that
property we're thinking about the ways
properties and things relate themselves
to each other in general
and he's right you know these properties
are to a certain degree independent of
each other and only the only thing that
allows them to interpenetrate
is this medium so he says
the many are in their determinateness
simple universals themselves so we have
a universal
here right and each of these properties
is also a universal
so this is really quite extraordinary
isn't it
we have like a whole bag of universals
and they're all connected with each
other and we have a universal that's
able to take in
other universals and what this means is
we're able to describe the process we're
able to use
language which works with with
universals in order to make sense of
this we're able to think this
we're not just stuck going oh oh you
know and making
gestures and sounds that intend
something
we're able to communicate with each
other we're able to do this to such a
degree
that i can describe to you something
that you've not yet experienced by
taking building blocks and putting them
together
and you constructing them into some sort
of
thing in your imagination we do this all
the time
so he says um the many are
determined as simple universals
themselves he uses the example of salt
so let's actually follow through with
salt
the salt is a simple here and at the
same time manifold
the salt is white and also tart
or salty right it is uh also cubicle and
shape of a certain specific gravity
all these many properties are in a
single
universal here
in which therefore they interpenetrate
they're able to inter
connect with each other not
in themselves not in what they are
in themselves as universals but as
moments within
this greater unity that we ourselves
grasp
he says none has a different here from
the others but each is
everywhere in the same here in which the
others are the piece of chalk is white
throughout it's hard throughout
it's chalky throughout the salt is the
same way
at the same time without being separated
by different hairs they do not affect
each other in their inter penetrations
insofar as i'm writing on the board and
you see something white here what's the
qualities that actually are being
perceived by you the whiteness
also i suppose you could say the
ductability the malleability of the
chalk as well
but the fact that it's dry you don't
care about that neither does the
chalkboard
certainly not what you're getting
through this camera
there are certain properties that are
able to do what they do
independently of each other depending on
the context they're able to do that
because they interpenetrate
within this here that is the thing
so he says at the same time without
being separated
they don't affect each other the
whiteness does not affect the cubicle
shape
neither affects the tar taste on the
contrary since each is itself a simple
relating of self to self
each of them involves this circular
relation to self each of them is a
complex
whole because it is a universal
it leaves the others alone and is
connected with them only
by the indifferent
also this is white
and also dry and also
hard or if we're talking about salt this
is white
and also salty and also cubicle
we can multiply these properties as
much as we want the same sort of dynamic
would hold
he says this also is also
a pure universal itself or the medium
the thing hood which holds them together
in this way so what does it mean for
something to be
a thing let's pause here for a moment
for something to be a thing
means that it introduces
this also into the manifold
of its properties and it allows them to
interpenetrate with each other
and also to be radically distinct from
one another that's what a universal does
when we're thinking about
many pieces of chalk but now we're
thinking about how universals work
within sensible particulars that we are
grasping under universals